[Musica]
non voglio cambiare pianeta
non è una mia frase ma è la frase di
chiusura di una bellissima poesia di
pablo neruda e più di recente anche il
titolo della docu serie di lorenzo
jovanotti che vi invito a guardare
non voglio cambiare pianeta in parte
perché credo sia parecchio difficile
andiamo facciamo estrema fatica a
gestire il pagamento delle bollette
online figuriamoci portare l'umanità su
un altro pianeta ammesso e non concesso
che ne esista un altro così bello chiaro
in parte perché credo sia da vigliacchi
rovinare qualcosa colpevolmente poi
semplicemente
abbandonarla
vedete che lo crediamo no stiamo
affrontando la più grave crisi
esistenziale mai registrata e con gli
ultimi dati possiamo dire che
probabilmente la prossima estinzione di
massa è dietro l'angolo
non si tratta di noi della trama di un
film di fantascienza ma è la realtà e se
oggi ci troviamo proprio a questo punto
è perché non abbiamo prestato
adeguatamente ascolto agli ammonimenti
degli scienziati e alle urla diventate
sorde della terra anzi per dirla tutta
ci siamo tappati le orecchie pur di non
ascoltare
voglio continuare però con un'altra
citazione un po perché mi riporta
indietro nel tempo e un po perché l'ho
sempre sentita molto vicino al mio cuore
ed è questa
credo che avere la terra e non rovinarla
sia la più bella forma d'arte che si
possa desiderare
solo di recente ne ho compreso realmente
il significato e io della terra ne sono
sempre stata innamorata con occhi certo
così
adorabile
da parte di una bambina
con occhi più consapevoli di un'adulta
voglio raccontarvi una storia
quando ero bambino con i miei genitori
amavamo fare delle passeggiate in
montagna
io origini abruzzesi
e ma d'inverno di tanto in tanto ci
piaceva fare qualche passeggiata nei
boschi del nord darà sciare ci prepara
preparavamo attentamente la sera prima
per essere i primi sulle piste e di
tanto in tanto andavamo a fare colazione
lì dove sembra quasi di toccare il cielo
con un dito in un rifugio a 3000 metri
d'altezza dalle cui finestre si vedeva
un ghiacciaio bellissimo il ghiacciaio
presena
di anno in anno però più io crescevo è
più lui scompariva lentamente si stava
dissolvendo sotto i miei occhi
con lui si fondeva fondeva un po anche
del mio cuore oggi questo ghiacciaio non
esiste quasi più se non per un piccolo
lembo e probabilmente i miei figli non
farò in tempo a portarceli
vedete quello del cambiamento climatico
e dei suoi effetti è un argomento
vastissimo con tantissime ripercussioni
però questa è senz'altro quella che gli
ho potuto vedere sotto i miei occhi
vivere e fa molto male
secondo copernicus il 2021 è stato
globalmente l'anno con le temperature
più alte degli ultimi 5 e fa parte del
cluster degli ultimi sette più caldi
abbiamo visto
estati con 48 gradi in sicilia quindi
non tanto lontano da casa 18 in
antartide
abbiamo visto alluvioni in germania
belgio lussemburgo
quanto ad emissioni a concentrazioni di
anidride carbonica in atmosfera siamo a
18,76 parti per milione nel 1945 quando
io sono andata eravamo a 306 santa e
secondo la comunità scientifica
internazionale non dovremmo superare le
450 per mantenere la temperatura media
globale sotto il grado e mezzo
e attualmente marciamo ad un ritmo di
tre parti per milione l'anno
abbandoniamo per un secondo tutti questi
tecnicismi questi numeri queste cose
noiose a volte vero caliamoci in
un'atmosfera più pop
provate a guardare i vostri social
scommetto che la maggior parte delle
foto che avete pubblicato sono dei
ricordi di alcune delle vostre vacanze
e scommetto altrettanto che la maggior
parte di queste foto sono ritratti della
natura e delle sue bellezze per qualche
strano motivo me compresa
tendiamo a circondarci b scatti e
ritratti che c'è la ricordano
e allora se ci piace così tanto
perché la stiamo distruggendo a me pare
un controsenso
è come se scattasse una foto al nostro
cucciolo prima di abbandonarlo ad un
autogrill oppure facessimo un self con
la nostra metà della mela prima di darle
o dargli il benservito
è un meccanismo perverso e contorto
a quanto pare così
provate a pensarci a seguire un attimo
il mio ragionamento
tutto ciò che io non ho toccato con le
mie mani tutto ciò che
non è tangibile per me
tendo a tenerlo lontano a crederci pro
fino ad un certo punto e questo ci è
successo tante volte da piccoli pensate
al fuoco tutti non lo tocchiamo perché
ci siamo scottati e non ci sono bastati
gli avvertimenti dei nostri genitori
no l'abbiamo toccato e ci siamo scottati
lo stesso vale per il disastro
ambientale nessuno di noi o la maggior
parte di noi l'ha veramente toccato
ancora con mano sulla propria pelle e
allora se non l'ho toccato chiaro che
non esiste o quantomeno non è urgente
come vogliono farmi credere a tutti i
costi
non credo infatti che sia un caso che
nei negoziati sul clima e quali ho
partecipato e ho potuto vedere con i
miei occhi che negoziatori provenienti
dagli stati insulari o stati che
attualmente stanno soccombendo agli
effetti disastrosi del climate change
parlassero con le lacrime agli occhi
altri invece riuscivano a mantenere un
certo distacco riuscivano a parlarne
come se la faccenda non li riguardasse
in prima persona
nel 2019 ero ancora una studentessa in
scienze biologiche e partecipa ad una
conferenza organizzata dai ricercatori
della mia università
così i cfu fanno sempre comodo
però quella conferenza parlava di
cambiamenti climatici lessi qualche
pubblicazione qualche paper e capi che
quanto al cambiamento climatico stavamo
facendo sul serio e che non era
ideologia ma era scienza fino a prova
contraria
da quel giorno del 2019
scelsi di scendere in piazza anch'io
ovviamente non avrei avuto tempo di
diventare una scienziata e poter fare
qualcosa quindi cosa fare ok scendo in
piazza e mi sono unità le manifestazioni
verdi dei giovani da quel giorno di metà
febbraio sono passati tre anni
tre libri pubblicati per gruppo
mondadori
2 negoziati sul clima ai quali
per i quali sono stata scelta dalle
nazioni unite e rappresentare la voce
del mio paese la voce dei giovani del
mio paese e finalmente la laurea tanto
agognata in scienze biologiche
da quel giorno
ho ricevuto anche diversi riconoscimenti
quello del ministero degli affari esteri
per i diritti umani quello di forbes
under 30 per impatto sociale quello
della fondazione bongiorno a sostegno di
un progetto che è diventato poi
l'oggetto della mia tesi di laurea
volto a sfruttare le microalghe per
produrre idrogeno verde da un lato e
purificare l'aria o acque reflue dalla
co2 e questo non è il punto il punto è
che probabilmente la stessa cosa in modi
diversi a successa nelle vite di tutti
gli altri ragazzi che hanno deciso di
abbracciare la sfida climatica e di
portare una piccola rivoluzione nel
mondo
tuttavia oggi dopo tutto ciò siamo quasi
al punto di inizio
onestamente il mio lavoro sebbene io lo
ami e non lo cambierei per nulla al
mondo non è affatto bello
tutti i giorni c'è il bollettino della
brutta notizia per l'ennesima volta il
treno dell'ambiente ha deragliato e c'è
un titan e chi in rotta di collisione
per dirne una secondo sempre la comunità
scientifica internazionale con gli
accordi che abbiamo siglato a cup 26 non
riusciremo a mantenere il mondo sotto il
grado e mezzo e siamo già verso i piu
2,7 gradi e questo innescherà meccanismi
irreversibili effetti atmosferici sempre
di portata maggiore
a novembre di quest'anno novembre 2021
dopo youth for climate che l'assise dei
giovani che organizzata sempre un evento
sempre di coop 26 che aveva l'obiettivo
di farci firmare un documento da poi
portare mostrare ai grandi della terra
nella speranza che ovviamente fosse
preso in considerazione
ho avuto l'immenso privilegio e
l'immenso onore di poter tenere un
discorso di fronte a sua santità papa
francesco
autorità religiose e civili erano
curiosi di sapere quali fossero le
istanze dei giovani e sapere cosa
volevamo
vedete sono tornata a casa con un
grandissimo regalo papà francesco ci ha
ricordato come dobbiamo smetterla di
credere a tutti coloro che vogliono
convincerci del fatto che noi giovani
sono il futuro i giovani salveranno il
pianeta
permettetemi di aggiungere è una
grandissima menzogna
è una menzogna perché come dice papà
francesco i giovani sono il presente e
il mondo
se proprio lo salveremo solo tutti
insieme
ci ha detto in altre parole di
continuare a fare rumore ed è proprio di
questo rumore che voglio provare a
parlarvi oggi
quando si prende coscienza della crisi
ambientale di un dramma così evidente
pervadente talvolta si resta
pietrificati
sopraffatti si pensa che noi non potremo
mai risolvere qualcosa di così distante
è grande ed è vero è buio c'è tanto fumo
c'è tanta nebbia non si vede
praticamente nulla ma di tanto in tanto
all'orizzonte compare qualche piccola
luce
piccole buone notizie per farvi qualche
esempio ovviamente ok giovani ma ma non
solo c'è chi scende in piazza che lo fa
da tanti anni per manifestare chi invece
un giovane medico e vuole studiare gli
effetti dei cambiamenti climatici sulla
nostra salute dato che ne avremo a che
fare e chi si occupa di divulgazione chi
cerca appunto di dare voce alla scienza
chi ancora bambino chiede ai propri
genitori di fare di più e chi ha capito
che quantomeno per coerenza
le piccole azioni contano e possono fare
la differenza anche in virtù di chiedere
alle istituzioni
qualcosa e allora decide di abbracciare
e diete sostenibili o semplicemente
mangiare un po meno carne decide di
viaggiare leggero decide di riciclare
tutto con estrema attenzione
e allora vi starete chiedendo ok qualche
buona notizia c'è ma la maggior parte
sono negative e allora perché continui
perché continui con questa attività o
con questo lavoro
in realtà lo scegli di diventare
attivista lo sai e basta
quanto al mio lavoro
non avrei mai pensato personalmente di
diventare una biologa o una divulgatrice
anzi tutt'altro onestamente
però all'idea di poter comunicare la
scienza di poter far nascere un briciolo
di consapevolezza ma soprattutto di
speranza
affinché questi ultimi sette anni e non
saranno spesi invano
ricordate sette anni non è teoria e
scienza dopo questi sette anni gli
eventi atmosferici estremi che già
stiamo vivendo saranno progressivamente
più forti più violenti ma soprattutto
imprevedibili e il che personalmente mi
preoccupa
oggi viaggiamo
verso la giusta direzione anche se
ancora a carbone
è la vera domanda che di tanto in tanto
mi pongo è
faremo in tempo
beh se presteremo attenzione alla
corrente dell'azione concreta e se lo
faremo veramente allora maggiore sarà
l'ascolto e maggiori di conseguenza le
probabilità di salvarci dato che il
tempo corre molto veloce e probabilmente
abbiamo ancora molto molto su cui
riflettere in merito al fatto che la
natura non appartiene proprio a nessuno
se non a ciascuno di noi
è così la terra continuerà in ogni caso
a girare attorno al suo asse e tutte le
specie viventi che la popolano si
adatteranno come hanno sempre fatto in
passato il problema sarà il nostro dato
che gli scienziati nessuno scienziato è
in grado di garantirci la sopravvivenza
su questo pianeta ma c'è un ma
se presteremo ascolto anzi se se
prestiamo ascolto oggi se agiamo bene
possiamo ancora essere in tempo per fare
in modo di non dover mai più dire
io non voglio cambiare pianeta grazie
[Applauso]